I just wanna I don't usually do this I
just want to point out that guy right
there I love this guy
let's get a shot of him look at this guy
right here I'm pointing him out cuz he's
having such a great time tonight he's
like you're like an amazing audience
member damn right I am
aye sir what's your name
Adam okay Adam you've been laughing
you've been applauding all night you're
just like one of the best audience
members I've ever seen I sure AM Conan
just a heads up my name is Adam winters
aka the great audience member you can
hit me up on Facebook or Instagram and
also Twitter and I'm also on snapchat
and of course you can always head over
to great audience member com
what would you love you just we had a
nice bumper coat and you just ruined it
why Adam what Conan is trying to say is
that your enjoyment of the show was
palpable and he felt a connection with
you and then you ruined that with a
self-indulgent long-winded promotion of
your social media accounts it's exactly
yes yes thank you sir that was a perfect
explanation no problem Conan I'm great
at explaining things if you need
explaining on any subject at all let me
Roger Michaelson aka the explainer
explain it check me out on LinkedIn on
my Roger explains Facebook page and I'm
also on Twitter and Instagram at Roger
explains as well as Pinterest and
snapchat and I also have a website Roger
the explainer com
[Applause]
see no see it's the same now I thought I
had a real connection with you and you
ruined it
oh come on Conan we live in
self-promotional times that's just the
way it is that last line brought to you
by craisins Jess stop interacting with
the audience and just get on with the
show they're just gonna keep doing it
okay all right good idea and a really
good idea but first check me out on Team
Coco dot-com or be one of the 20 million
plus you follow me on Twitter Facebook
Instagram Pinterest YouTube tumblr
periscope and if you want to play xbox
against me find me a username comb bone
[Applause]
honey come on isn't it enough that the
show has your name on it
you're a you're right Andy that that
didn't feel right you know it does feel
right shiatsu massage to book your
appointment with me and my magic fingers
look for the avocado color Dodge Caravan
outside Ralph's in Burbank just knock on
the window
I'm usually sleeping inside
[Applause]
you